audience is a split on whether glass the
third part of M night Shyamalan grounded
superhero trilogy is a fitting
conclusion to the series
yippee guy may be lovers I'm Jan and in
this video I'm explaining everything you
need to know about the ending to glass
and that surprise twist plus some
crucial details and hidden messages you
might have missed
obviously spoilers ahead so take care if
you haven't seen the movie yet twist
endings are M night Shyamalan trademark
and glass is no exception with an ending
that's likely to be divisive among the
audience the final showdown that mr.
glass aka Elijah price has set up
outside the hospital sees the beast to
take on David Dern who's known as the
overseer Elijah wants to reveal the
existence of superheroes to the world
but when Kevin and David are both killed
by God's called him by Sarah Paulsen's
dr. staple the movie reveals that dr.
staplers actually been working for a
secret society that suppresses
super-powered individuals and aims to
keep their existence under wraps the
idea for this twist goes back to 1999
when Shyamalan was working on the script
for unbreakable and a Monkees file of
notes for that film he wrote down the
question how come nobody knows about
these superheroes the answer of course
is this secret society which has been
concealing the existence of superheroes
in the world for around 10,000 years and
this revelation basically confirms
Elijah's comic-book theory that he
expressed in unbreakable the Egyptians
chew on walls countries all over the
world still pass on knowledge through
pictorial forms I believe comics are
form of history that someone somewhere
felt or experienced despite Kevin and
David having been murdered in glass dr.
staple explains to Elijah that comics
are wrong about secret groups being evil
because the secret society she works for
doesn't choose sides rather their goal
is to maintain balance and order in
society because it's not fair to have
gods among ordinary human beings the
problem as dr. staple sees it is that
whenever one super-powered individual
pops up his or her opposite also then
appears and the situation escalates the
unbreakable split and glass trilogy
demonstrates that perfectly unbreakable
was the origin story of David Dunn as a
super strong and powerful hero and split
which was a secret sequel was about the
emergence of the
a villain the Beast these two characters
then face off directly in spectacular
fashion at the beginning of glass we're
done hunting down and battling the beast
when he rescues the cheerleaders
kidnapped by the Horde by the way the
showdown between these two in glass was
foreshadowed all the way back in
unbreakable when the young Elijah
unwrapped his first comic book the
battle would jaguaro
done who was a green poncho is
represented by the caped hero on the
left and the Beast aka the Horde whose
signature color is yellow is jaguaro on
the right interestingly in glass we
discover that Elijah is not only
responsible for David's existence as a
super-powered individual but also for
the Beast because the train derailment
that Elijah caused in unbreakable and
which only David survived also killed
Kevin's father which in turn led to the
creation of the Horde inside Kevin
Elijah proudly proclaims that by
engineering this event he's a mastermind
who creates superheroes and in another
curious connection between David and the
Beast David's son Joseph went to the
same school as KC and the two girls
abducted and split now the way the
secret society and glass operates is
that they move from city to city
identifying super-powered individuals
and they have a process for dealing with
them witch doctor staple claims is
humane they begin by gaslighting the
individuals in other words trying to
convince them that they have delusions
of grandeur has dr. staple attempted to
do with Elijah David in Kevin at the
psychiatric hospital she almost
succeeded with David in the Horde with
David beginning to doubt his powers and
Patricia telling Elijah that her horde
is losing faith the second stage that
dr. staple employs with individuals like
mr. glass he refused to be convinced is
to perform a kind of lobotomy and remove
or eliminate a part of their brain she
attempts the medical procedure on Elijah
but unbeknown to her when he broke out
of his cell the night before he went
into the surgery room and sabotage the
equipment so it didn't do anything to
him during the procedure the final stage
the society undertakes in the event the
first two failing is to completely
eliminate the individual which is what
happens when David and Kevin are taken
out by the Society's henchmen by the way
there was a chilling bit of
foreshadowing in one of the glass
trailers of how dr. staple held David
Dunn's hand and watched
while he was drowned in the puddle so
you're not gonna shake my hand and let
me walk out of here and it was even
foreshadowed in the scene from
unbreakable when David says to Elijah to
skinny little kids were fooling around
and a pool dunking me and I swallowed
some water they didn't know it and it
almost killed me
purists not get killed like that normal
people do right and if you're unclear
how the Beast could be killed with a
bullet after he survived - at close
range and split what happened was that
Cayce embraced the Beast and through her
connection with Kevin and by saying his
full name repeatedly Kevin was able to
take the light from the Beast that meant
that Kevin no longer had super thick
skin like the Beast so when the sniper
shot him injured him as it would any
ordinary human being in terms of who the
secret society might represent it's not
made explicit in the movie but there is
a hint by the Shamrock tattoo that dr.
staple the henchman and the members who
meet at the restaurant have near their
wrists clovers were considered magical
plants in Celtic culture and there are
legends of st. Patrick using a three
leaf clover to explain what the
Christian Holy Trinity symbolized if we
think of clovers as having a magical or
spiritual meaning the secret societies
clover tattoos may signify how the
organization is dedicated to suppressing
magical or godlike powers in society
Shyamalan himself in fact has said that
what makes us different is our strength
but dr. staple believes in the status
quo she believes in the way that it is
right now and she can't see past that
there is still one final twist in this
story and although dr. staple told
Elijah his theory was right all along it
seemed like she contained the situation
at the hospital even if it meant Elijah
Kevin and David all ended up dead
however as we know Elijah is a Lex
Luthor style genius and even calls
himself a mastermind and the night that
Elijah broke out of his cell after
switching his sedatives for aspirin he
reprogrammed the security camera so that
send all recorded footage off-site then
during the outbreak Elijah deliberately
took the Beast through the basement as
he knew that that area was monitored
with cameras and that the parking lot
fight would all be caught on camera - in
the final scenes of the movie
Elijah's mother Joseph and Casey
received the footage and agreed to
upload the evidence to the internet for
anyone to see a couple of hours later
they meet at a location that's been
crucial throughout the trilogy the
trains
nation and the movie ends as we see the
footage start to go viral popping up on
people's phones and devices and on the
TV news and in a nice little final nod
to the three fallen supers at the end of
the film mrs. price Casey and joseffer
each dressed in the signature colors of
Elijah purple Kevin yellow and David
Green as these scenes play we hear
Elijah's voiceover telling us there are
unknown forces that don't want us to
realize what we are truly capable of I
believe that if everyone sees what just
a few people become when they wholly
embrace their gifts others will awaken
whoever these people are who don't want
us to know the truth
today they lose the real message at
Shyamalan seems to want to tell us in
class is that difference is a strength
and extraordinary abilities are within
the grasp of many people on top of that
the three films and breakable split and
glass exists to prove there can be
grounded and realistic superhero stories
this our difference the more fantastical
superhero stories we typically see in
franchises like the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and many other comic-book
movies in a breakable and glass Elijah
always emphasizes that although
real-life superheroes exist they look
very different to those in comic books
the thing to notice about this piece the
thing that makes it very very special is
its realistic depiction of its figures
when the characters reach the magazine
they were exaggerated as always happens
it's alright to be afraid David because
this part won't be like a comic book
real life doesn't fit into little boxes
double drama in glass at one point
Elijah says this is not a cartoon this
is the real world and just before Pierce
is killed by the Beast he jokes that
this is where they would paint you with
big eyes and bubbles of confusion
the Osaka Tower were Elijah threatens to
stage the final showdown is referred to
as a true Marvel in a wink to the famous
comic book publisher and movie studio so
when it's revealed that Elijah's threat
is just a ruse and the showdown was
always planned in the less showy setting
of the hospital car park
Shyamalan is deliberately pointing out
that this isn't meant to be a big-budget
superhero blockbuster with an epic CGI
finale where the hero goes home after
defeating the villain this choice is
perhaps one of the reasons why some
viewers haven't enjoyed the movies
ending after all some fans have been
waiting nearly two decades for the
sequel to embraceable and since then
we've all been exposed to a deluge of
superhero movies and big-budget
comic-book movies are typically the most
hyped tempo releases right now glass
kicked off with a thrilling starters dun
rescue the cheerleaders from the Beast
but the rest of the movie played out
more like a slow burn psychological
thriller and I suspect some in the
audience were indeed hoping for the
final showdown to take place on the
Asarco tower so when instead two of the
main characters are killed in a much
more understated fashion by some
nameless henchmen from a secret society
that's bound to provoke a reaction the
thing is though that that's what the
movie wants to do it's pointing out that
real-life heroes and villains don't have
these epic fights and these characters
aren't invincible the low-key nature of
the final showdown in glass is also in
keeping with the feel of both
unbreakable and split so it would have
been odd for the film to suddenly pivot
to an epic climax on top of the shiny
skyscraper the movie intends to subvert
flashy superhero tropes and instead
prove that the big spectacles we see on
film or in comic books are just an
exaggerated version of more realistic
yet still extraordinary powers people
can have in real life in light of this
it's also interesting that on her desk
dr. staple has a book by Euripides a
playwright in ancient Greece whose
tragedies are often noted for their
realistically drawn characters
psychological realism and mythical
heroes portrayed as ordinary people
living through extraordinary situations
glass doesn't achieve the brilliance of
unbreakable and falls into Shama lands
trap of inserting too much exposition
into the mouths of his characters
there's an overabundance of explain
literally what we've just seen are about
to see on screen for example when mrs.
price comes on to tell us that this is
what they call the showdown it seems a
pretty redundant line to have in a movie
released in 2019 given that almost
everyone will be familiar with comic
book movies by now and Shyamalan has
some great actors in his film but his
insistence on sticking firmly to a
script and generally not allowing actors
to improvise also seems to lead to some
rather clunky lines something that fans
were inevitably interested in is whether
glass represents the final chapter in
the unbreakable and split universe
obviously all the main characters are
dead however the final scene implies
we'll see new heroes and villains emerge
and any of those could be explored in
future movies or a TV show so far
Shyamalan a said he's not particularly
keen for another follow up as with the
exception of this trilogy he generally
doesn't do sequels glass is also
supposed to be a satisfying conclusion
to the series and for me it seems in
keeping with the idea of a grounded
superhero series not to expand it out
into a much larger franchise now what do
you think about the end of glass and
what were your favorite or least
favorite parts of the movie let me know
in the comments below
if you're new here and enjoyed this then
every week I have new movie breakdown so
do subscribe and hit the bell to get all
my new videos there's another glass
video on the way and you can tap left to
watch that as soon as it's ready what a
pride for another video you're sure to
like thanks for watching and see you
next time you pick a movie lovers